well I still love you after this I think
so I could probably wear this out I
think oh my god it's like the same
outfit yeah so there's the polo on top
blue cargo shorts everyone had the multi
pocketed shorts I still had this like um
huge passion for Disney I used to wear a
bra and then wear a sports bra over
because my boobs just grew so fast I
actually used to wear all of my dad's
clothes from when he was in high school
I always wore lots of color
I loved Hawaiian shirts mini skirt the
layered like spaghetti strap tops with
like a shawl over the top or something
and some sandals he only likes blue so I
think he just wears like blue jeans blue
shirts he probably had a little more
like sophisticated style than I did for
sure so I'm assuming it with a lot of
plaid babe will you still love me if I
look like a goober depends what kind of
guru yes I feel like we're role-playing
oh oh what does that say dawn in the
ginger door that's the size you are you
look really cute babies aren't skin
tight I know that that's why I wanted it
look but they look good honey
Thanks yeah these are like your jeans
mom D it's cute
I would like to talk today yeah I can
phone each other for you skinnier what
do you mean was it bigger he really
think Oh they've receded I'm coming out
all right I'm ready yeah
your preppy Oh where's that we believe
we're is a little too tight for me I'd
say but yeah it shows your move
no wonder you had had sex with women
you're like gonna go get a mojito yeah
wait what does he say
religions a bag [ __ ] happens and it
happens to snow good or were there some
money I probably would've worn on a
Friday - you know I clean it high school
did you like it - probably like my best
friend's mother I feel like we look like
we would have been friend yeah I
probably wouldn't like even have noticed
him I thought you would have been my
cooler what a sorrow thighs for Union
and I don't who she was so they makes me
want to watch Dawn of the Dead now I
don't even eat we can watch everyday I
feel like this was like seeing each
other naked for the first take it let
you know